a blue whale's blowhole
is so large that a baby could fit inside
it
thankfully no babies are stuck in whales
in this episode
but you are how
powerfully can a whale exhale
if you were stuck in a blowhole what
would happen to the whale
and would you be able to escape
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if you were sucked into a whale's
blowhole
like you and me whales have lungs
they don't have gills though so they
can't breathe
underwater but unlike us
whales can hold their breath for a long
time
they can be under water for up to 30
minutes
and deep diving whales like sperm whales
can survive for over an hour without
coming up for air
but eventually they all have to come to
the surface for air which
they suck in using their large blow
holes
it's during one of these moments that
somehow
you find your foot getting stuck in a
massive blowhole
this is bad news for you and the whale
you can think of blowholes as nostrils
on top of a whale's head but
they're much more powerful than human
nostrils
after each breath strong muscles seal
the blowhole shut
to keep water from entering the whale's
lungs
when whales exhale they shoot out 90
of their old air and since you only
exhale
12 to 18 of your old air after each
breath
90 is a lot of air to release
in a single moment it's so much air that
one exhalation from a whale can travel
at speeds of up to 482 kilometers per
hour
and reach 9 meters into the air
that is one big sign
whales that have teeth and are active
hunters known as
toothed whales only have one blowhole
but baleen whales which don't have teeth
and feet on krill usually have two
blowholes because
they're larger and need more oxygen
it's one of these larger whales that
your foot is stuck in
how would that feel well it would be
painful
and the strong blowhole muscles would
make it
extremely difficult for you to get your
foot out
you'd still be struggling as the whale
submerges and
water surges over your head can you hold
your breath
for as long as a whale yeah i didn't
think so
if the whale doesn't dive then you'd
have a chance to get free
typically whales take one to two breaths
per minute when they're swimming at the
surface you'd be able to gulp in
some oxygen every time the whale came up
for air
your best chance to free yourself would
be when the whale exhales
the opening of the blow hole combined
with the violent exhale of
air and microbes could be just enough
to propel you to freedom and
the whale would be happy to see you go
some whales are very conscious of their
blowholes and
don't like anything touching them
whales can't breathe through their
mouths and even with a second blowhole
to breathe with
the whale wouldn't be getting enough
oxygen for its
massive body and with your leg
obstructing a blowhole
water would leak into the whale's lungs
so
if you didn't get your foot out of the
whale's blowhole
both of you would die from suffocation
luckily you have a bigger chance of
being swallowed by a whale than
getting sucked into its blowhole or
maybe that's not so lucky
but that's a story for another
what if
[Music]